c'est que on est les rush puisque toute
la phrase est en off donc le Off tu peux
l'utiliser sur N pas trist attends j'ai
deux autres éléments à
apporter JIS répondre on verra va
peut-être pas me répondre mais bon si il
m'interpell bien dans
les c'est évidemment très grave mais
surtout il devrait pouvoir pour éteindre
la polémique puisqu'il y en a une a un
certain nombre de journalistes qui
s'interroge il faut qu'il diffuse le
vrai in c'estàdire à quel moment Gérard
de pardieu dit ça qu' qu qui il désigne
à ce moment-là et dans les souvenirs de
de l'équipe de reportage il y a un autre
moment où il y a un un touriste canadien
qui justement a une action assez
déplacée à l'égard d'une jeune fille et
ça c'est dans le film de Yan wax et
gerérard de pardieu va voir ce ce ce
touriste canadien avec la fille qui
l'accompagne la guide et lui demande
d'arrêter d'importuner une petite fille
donc il a en plus une action j'ai envie
de dire responsable vis-à-vis des
petites filles donc il y a cet élément
là aussi et ça Yan MOX aimerait bien et
se demande pourquoi s avait mon
veonécupère oui il aimerait bien que
cette séquence soit diffusé parce que ça
enfin ça ENF ça éclaire les choses d'un
autre façonus mais si ce que vous dites
est vrai c'est catastrophique il y a il
y a énormément tout et j'apporte un
dernier élément pardon c'est que la
traductrice et ça il y a des preuves
irréfutables la traductrice qui est
prise pour enfin à qui Gérard pardieu
s'exprimerait de façon déplacée à écrit
postérieurement au tournage en en disant
des choses extrêmement agréables à
l'égard de gerérardo pardiot sur son
comportement ça ils l'ont pas pris ça
bizarrement non moi je j'aurais bien
aimé que l'équipe de complément
d'enquête s'intéresse à ceux qui étaient
présents sur place pour savoir qu'est-ce
qu'ils en
disent j'appelle Tristan je pense pas
qu'il répond on va voir on va essayer
bah moi il sont bien ven bien venu me
faire chier dans la
rue moi j'ai le droit de les faire chier
quand même c'est bon Tristan Wex 3è
sonnerie je rappelle que tristanex joue
pour la
cagnotte 52 € Tristan Wex tristanex de
la région
parisienne le jeune Tristan est
recherché je laiss un message je pense
qu'il aime bien quand je
l'appelle alors pour être tout à fait
équilibré aussi il faut ajouter une
chose c'est que qu' ve lui oui non mais
je voudrais pas il se peut aussi que le
producteur a fait des choses entre
guillemets dans le dos de l'équipe de de
complément donc je je je n'en sais rien
de ça voilàr bien sûr non mais non mais
tous les parce que ce que vient de dire
Jacques est parfaitement vrai tous les
et beaucoup de journalistes dans Paris
aujourd'hui essayent de savoir ça et ce
qui est inquiétant c'est que ça fait une
semaine que la question est posé que il
y a toujours pas ni les rush ni ni quoi
que ce soit ni une ouverture de porte ça
pourrait se débloquer dans les heures
dans les jours qui viennent et autre
chose parce que tout à l'heure tu
parlais du film de yanx aujourd'hui le
producteur le fameux producteur
laissez-moi un message merci à la fin de
votre message si vous souhaitez le
modifier tapez diz trist don enquête de
complément euh je suis en train
d'enquêter sur le complément d'enquête
concernant Gérard pardieu et on a
quelques éléments troublants on aimerait
bien vous parler donc si vous voulez
bien nous rappeler tu connais mon numéro
Tristan ou bien venir même sur le
plateau pour nous en parler parce que
c'est vrai qu'il y a des éléments
troublants dans le complément d'enquête
de Gérard pardieu et on aimerait bien
avoir le film Tristan le film le film de
Yan wax si tu l'as chez toi n'hésite pas
à m'inviter je viendrai même pendant les
vacances j'ai rien à
à partir de vendredi je suis libre donc
voilà donc rappelle-moi et sinon
envoie-moi un petit un petit message
mais là c'est pas Nouna l'animateur qui
t'appelle là c'est
l'enquêteur à tout à l'heure j'espère
qu'il va me rappeler alors et sur le
film de Yan aujourd'hui le producteur
prétend que ce film n'existe pas il mais
si jamais ce film a été fait que Yan le
montre moi je vrais juste témoign d'une
chose c'est que je l'ai vu moi ce film
Yann avant toute cette histoire me
l'avait envoyé il y a 2 mois il avait
une version en fait on pouvait le lire
VI enfin le voir VI un lien privé il me
l'avait envoé vous voyez je l'avais vu
ça du 2h et de c'est objectivement
génial ça ressemble au documentaire de
Gérard de pardieu habituel c'est
vraiment vraiment super et je l'ai vu et
aujourd'hui lui prétend que ce film
n'existe pas et ça pour le coup je peux
témoigner moi vraiment que si il existe
moi je vais vous dire ce ce qui me Dér
j'ajoute un point là-dessus cyil c'est
que 2 jours avant la diffusion du
complément d'enquête le lien qui
permettait de voir le film a été
supprimé lui il demande à ce que ce soit
rétabli évidemment parce qu'il veut que
d'autres journalistes puissent voir ce
film de 2h de dont il dit le plus grand
bien des éléments troublants alors
justement il y a un truc qui me qui me
dérange c'est que tout le monde derrière
s'engouffre dans la brèche dont la
ministre de la Culture Rima Abdou Malak
qui a annoncé
l'ouverture d'une l'ouverture d'une
procédure disciplinaire pouvant aboutir
au retrait la Légion d'honneur de
l'acteur regardez Rima Abdou malac qui
s'est exprimé toujours bien sûr avec
beaucoup de bon sens une légion
d'honneur ça
distingue un homme un artiste et une
attitude des valeurs c'est tout ça à la
fois une légion d'honneur il a un
conseil de l'Ordre de la Légion
d'honneur qui va se réunir et qui va
engager une procédure disciplinaire pour
décider si cette légion d'honneur doit
être suspendue ou pas retiré
complètement ou pas ça sera eux décider
évidemment Gérard de Padieu pourra
apporter des éléments contradictoires
c'est une
procédure qui va être enclenché voilà
alors qui fait beaucoup de plateau hein
tout tous les jours est sur France 5 ou
sur TMC ou voilà on pe elle peut venir
jerois ne pouvait pas influer sur la vie
judiciaire de quelqu d'un d'une elle
influe sur tout elle ouais Maisin je
dire qu'elle puiss s'exprimer alors que
gerarde n'est pas jugé et que se la jus
te dire je don un exemple je vais donne
un exemple l'arcom c'est une entité qui
fait vraiment ce qu'il veut c'est
vraiment ils sont libres l'État n'a pas
interféré sur avant une décision nous
concernant un jour avant elle a été
faire toutes les télés pour dire il faut
qu'il y ait une grosse sanction pour
cyilouna voilà
donc la vérité voilà elle elle elle
essaie vraiment de d'exister tu sais
mais c'est souvent ça les ministres de
la Culture malheureusement tu sais nous
ça fait 13 ans qu'on est là et des
ministres de la Culture on en a vu
passer je peux te dire tu vois et c'est
vrai qu'on est plus souvent là que faut
pas trop s'attacher à celle-là je pense
non moi non plus ouais je pense aussi
pourquoi Emmanuel Macron il l'a défoncé
après ça mais en fait nous on a voulu
savoir du coup si elle si elle agissait
au nom de tout le gouvernement ou si
elle avait parlé en son nom propre et
l'Élisée nous a fait savoir que que
Macron était pas au courant il était pas
très content et que par ailleurs il y a
quand même un problème de de présomption
d'innocence c'est qu'elle est elle est
en train de retirer al ces films sont
plus diffusés sur service public de par
Dieu quand même le plus grand er me M''
er il m' dit un mec qui m'a écrit ou je
sais pas je sais pas qui cétait
attendant de France Télé il y a ça
ensuite il y a la statue au musée Grévin
au nom de quoi et et cette légion de il
on droit alors grvin les pauv grin les
pauv pars ont des
menacesess faire Maxou les visiteurs les
visiteurs étaient très mécontents c'est
vrai sur les réseaux sociaux ils se
faisaient vraiment insulter donc du coup
ils ont décidé d'enlever la statue pour
me pas été condamné quoi c'est ça c'est
un pe oui ouiat je dire juste une phrase
que geoffro JAAC vous entends certes il
y a un montage il est dégueulasse c'est
évidemment très très grave mais il faut
pas oublier que parallèlement parce que
vous parlez de oui mais il y a une
nouvelle il y a une nouvelle plainte qu'
vio comme on a dit on a dit attendons
attendons ce que va dire la
jus Benjamin
mend mais justeal attendez faites pas
une r malacêes
bien pour l'instant il y a la justice
qui va faire travail sur ça c'est des
fait des fait voilà est les on est train
d'quter explioute une chose c c'est
qu'il faudrait pas que les r disparus
que les r été détruit ce que demande
yanx et son entourage c'est évidemment
de pouvoir voir le matériel compris les
R donc j'espère que le producteur et
France 2 On détruiront pas on va se
retrouver dans un instant avec Miss
France 2024 n voir et Cindy Fabre qui
est tout le temps avec elle c'est comme
RIM Abdou malac avec Emmanuel Macron à
tout de
[Applaudissements]
suite